today we're gonna talk about the brain
and how to keep your brain really young
and healthy sound good
okay so the raw material of the brain
which basically makes up the structure a
good portion of it is something called
DHA this is you know mega 3 fatty acid
okay comes from fish shellfish and
definitely cod liver oil and salmon so
you want to start consuming more fish to
get more of this to give your brain what
it needs structurally and in a growing
child it's extremely important but in a
pregnant female it's even more important
now the fuel that the brain prefers is
ketones way over glucose it does need a
certain amount of glucose but don't
worry about that because your body can
make glucose from ketones and from fat
and from protein so we don't need to
consume glucose to feed our brain
prefers ketones if you have glucose and
ketones in the blood the brain will
always take ketones first so if you're
transitioning to ketosis and let's say
you have an insulin resistance or you're
pre-diabetic or you're diabetic and it
takes longer
you can add MCT oil to beef up no pun
intended your ketones to basically get
more ketones in your brain and your
brain will be happier you'll have more
energy so let's talk about the different
ways your brain can become damaged one
way is to deprive it of magnesium now
when you have a subclinical magnesium
deficiency maybe you don't consume
enough vegetables or food with magnesium
the energy that's generated in little
factories called mitochondria and your
neurons are going to be deprived and
you're gonna lose the quantity and the
density of these synapses okay so
magnesium is really really important
there's a type of magnesium that works
way better for the brain than other
types of magnesium magnesium l three and
eight this magnesium has a special
quality of penetrating the blood-brain
barrier going in there and restoring
these synapses and increasing the
density of them
and it's great for increasing memory
cognitive function learning and
extending your sleep a little longer as
well but don't forget to consume the
green foods and I'm not talking about
lime green jello or pistachio ice cream
I'm talking about vegetables
okay now iron is a very toxic mineral
for the brain and for the liver and for
the heart if it's in excess amounts
it's very corrosive it oxidizes the
brain if you find that you have high
iron it's a good idea to get tested EDTA
it's a key later will help remove the
excess just make sure you don't keep
putting it back in by consuming certain
supplements with a lot of iron I'm gonna
put a link down below with more
information on this specifically if you
haven't seen my video on iron it's
really important okay next thing is
atrophy of the brain if you have insulin
resistance or you're pre-diabetic or
you're diabetic what's going to happen
over time the brain is gonna have
atrophy it's going to shrink and that's
going to create a lot of problems with
your cognitive function to help mitigate
that or reverse that you want to do
ketosis how do you ketosis you would
drop your carbs and you do intermittent
fasting real simple now certain parts of
the brain have the capacity to grow new
neurons thank goodness the parts of the
brain that are involved with memory can
regenerate so to get new brain cells
Henneman fasting is probably the most
important thing and also regular
consistent exercise can also help with
that and it'll also increase this other
thing called BDNF brain-derived
neurotrophic factor which is like
miracle-gro
for your brain and these are the two
triggers there's other triggers as well
okay zinc very important in preventing
something called amyloid plaque Ignatz
involved in Alzheimer's so this is kind
of a type of protein that accumulates in
this area right here of the synapses and
it interferes with the communication
between the brain and you start getting
dementia so zinc is very very important
into preventing this the other thing
that's really important in getting rid
of ammo like locking is in a minute
fasting in periodic prolonged fasting
cellphones
very very dangerous to your brain okay
especially when you're holding it right
here never hold your cell phone you're
gonna get EMF if you haven't seen my
video on that you definitely need to
watch it this is not weird or a myth or
something it's real you need I put a
link down below but do not touch the
cell phone to your skull while you're
talking like this hold it out here or
have on speakerphone and definitely
don't use the Bluetooth I talked more
about it in my video and there's a
couple of things that can counter EMF
radiation niacin at 50 milligrams per
day would be good also intermittent
fasting is very beneficial vestrum oils
which caused a lot of oxidation and it's
similar to the effects that glucose will
give you as well as iron so do not
consume corn oil canola cottonseed and
soy oil instead olive oil is much better
okay over here we have hypoxia okay
that's a situation where you're you have
a loss of oxygen in certain parts of
your brain that could come from many
things let's see you had trauma to the
head at some point let's say it a stroke
CIA your your parents dropped you on
your head is a baby or we have sleep
apnea and you're restricting the oxygen
to your brain a couple things to do one
is a robic exercise that's getting out
there walking or riding your bike or a
jog consistently every day that will
increase the oxygen to the brain the
other thing that's really hot is this
hyperbaric oxygen therapy I'm gonna put
a link down below but hyperbaric oxygen
therapy has some serious hardcore
research behind it it's extremely
effective and you'll definitely want to
know more about it especially if you
wanted to fix this right here you
basically put it in a container and the
oxygen is increased to nearly a hundred
percent normally the air that you
breathe
it's like 21% oxygen well in a
hyperbaric chamber they're gonna
increase it close to 100% and with all
the pressure involved it's going to
force oxygen into your lungs into your
blood cells into the entire tissues up
into the brain so if there's any areas
of damaged or pockets of hypoxia or
ischemia which is a lack of oxygen
oxygen it'll feed that and help heal
those tissues they use it for many many
conditions but it's great for your brain
next thing is ketones run your bun and
ketones will increase the o2 and
decrease the co2 now there's another
condition which I believe many people
have a subclinical version of this but
it's called wernicki Korsakoff this is a
b1 deficiency it's gonna affect your
memory especially in the development of
new memories
it's gonna affect your gait eventually
can bring you to apathy affect your
vision and sleep apnea simple b1 a lot
of people are deficient in b12 they
don't even know it why are people
deficient in B 1 because it's involved
in the energy factory mitochondria the
cell when you're dealing with glucose so
if you're doing glucose or refined
carbohydrates or sugar you're gonna burn
up your b1 very fast and you're gonna
create a deficiency so glucose high
fructose corn syrup alcohol white rice
will just burn this up and start to
develop these conditions right here
there's a lot of other conditions that a
deficiency of b1 can create as well I
put a link down below in the description
of a talk I did on b1 at the summit in
2018 if you haven't seen that that's a
really good presentation now when you're
deficient in iodine okay it can affect
your IQ so if you'd like to keep your IQ
up iodine is the answer
alright selenium if you're deficient you
can have mercury toxicity because what
happens is if there's too much mercury
in the brain it can lock up the selenium
and that's involved in the antioxidant
Network glutathione for example and then
you're deficient in that and now
you you can't really get rid of all the
free radicals in the oxidation so
selenium is very very important and then
vitamin D which mostly part deficient in
that as well if you're low in vitamin D
you're gonna have way more inflammation
that you want of the brain as well also
you're not gonna have good sleep so
vitamin D is good for that so how could
you kind of condense all this data into
five things here we go
shellfish will give you sink copper
iodine selenium and DHA also if you add
in there other fish fatty fish halibut
salmon and also cod liver oil you're
gonna get it enough DHA as well the Sun
okay I get more Sun get more vitamin D
it's virtually impossible to get your
vitamin D from food so you have to get
it from Sun or just take it greens dark
leafy greens folate magnesium potassium
keto that's a given in a minute fasting
vital and regular exercise there you
have it this is the summary right here
thanks for watching
thank you